let's go to the phones which are functioning
a little bit weirdly today.
Let's try to start with someone I didn't get
to last time.
Ronald Reagan calling it Ronald.
What's going on?
Okay.
Hey David, how's it going?
Good.
How are you?
Um, you may remember, I know you don't like
to get into online progressive drama, but
I was a few months ago, I brought up that
you had somewhat copied the Sam Cedar majority
report set and the, the accusation was that
you were trying to coast stuff, you know,
Sam's a whatever is a intellectual property.
Right.
That was the, the idea.
But I just want to let you know, I had it
sort of, you know, the usual suspects.
Are you familiar with this film?
Yes, I am.
[inaudible]
yeah.
And you know how at the end that detective
sort of looks around, um, his, his office
and he realizes, uh, he, he's had everything
all wrong this whole time.
And I had a moment like that, uh, the other
day when I was listening to Sam's show and
a caller called in and said that, um, she
was new to his show and he asked, how, how
did you come to find out about the show?
And she said that she'd first started by listening
to you and, and that, um, you know, in the
YouTube recommendations or whatever, she actually
clicked over to Sam's show.
So it could be, um, it sounds like, to me
from the evidence that actually Sam was trying
to get you to adopt, uh, his intellectual
property to create confusion amongst your
audience, uh, so that your audience would,
uh, leak over into his a struggling podcast.
I think.
I think that's spot on.
In fact, I think that probably 80 or 90% of
Sam's audience is people thinking that I've
allowed someone else to use my studio.
I think you're making an incredibly astute
assessment here.
Yeah.
And it's a, you know, you're a smart guy,
but it's sad that you got tricked into doing
that, uh, by saying, yeah, but, um, but that's
OK. you know, I think that you're doing all
right.
I did want to ask you, um, because all jokes
aside, I really like your clips on YouTube
and I find myself, you know, just sort of
having the mind, I don't know anything about
like, uh, your scheduling or like when you
do your show, um, how often it is.
Um, and so I, I wish you would give somebody
like me who's kinda new to, uh, to your show
a rundown of exactly what you have to offer.
Right?
So we do, we do five episodes a week, Monday
to Friday.
We, uh, film it in the early afternoon and
then we start clipping it up doing a podcast
version and all of this stuff starts going
out.
I'll out around three 30 or 4:00 PM Eastern
time each weekday and then, so, you know,
we'll publish clips to YouTube from that day's
show that day.
We'll hold a couple for the weekends so that
we have stuff publishing each day of the week.
And then our radio and TV affiliates and satellite
TV run the show anywhere from like 5:00 PM
to 11:00 PM Eastern time that day from what
we filmed earlier in the afternoon.
I see.
And what is your preferred way of, uh, you
know, people supporting the show?
Is there a, you know, a Patriot or they need
to go to your website?
We have a Patrion but as people may know,
Patrion takes five to 9% depending on certain
factors that are boring to get into.
So the way for the majority of the money to
get to us is the website memberships cause
we just pay 2.9% for swiping credit cards
and then otherwise we get the rest.
So that's where we keep the most money when
people go to our website.
Alright.
Thanks dude.
All right, Ronald Reagan, great to hear from
you.
Always good.
We will be updating your, a rating in the
color system cause you were clear, concise
and direct, uh, during today's phone call.
I appreciate that.